hi my name is reka pal and i'm working
as a director of scientific scientific
engagement in crown bioscience and i
have a lot of expertise in oncology i
work in unity of pittsburgh for almost
14 years working with translational
cancer research using all preclinical
models cell line xenograft and PTX model
i worked with another clinical trial
group hop-ons a vp foundation which is
specific for the colorectal and breast
cancer and there i establish a
preclinical model using PDX organoids
and cell lines in graft paste so i would
like to thank you lab root for giving us
opportunity to present a ground by
organoid platform here at 20:20 drug
discovery virtual seminar so today my
topic is organoid our revolutionary new
tool for drug screening so as we know
you know there is a very pure trance
ability of the early stage preclinical
model which is a major setback for the
early time point discovery drug
discovery as we usually we are using
cell lines and the xenograft which is
quite homogenous system and also we have
seen lot of genetic drift in the cell
line over number of passages so these
models are not very closely we capsulate
the patient disease now from the last
failures PDX model has been developed
and they are models picking the current
model which recapitulate the patient
disease but definitely the models are
also very cost expensive the very time
taking and also involved the mice micro
environments from the cells so
definitely there is always they still
have a gap between the lab and clinic
and so we need to come up with some
model which closely mimic the patient
disease as well as cost-effective and
time efficient
so these a landmark discovery few years
back with dr. Hans hands cleavers crew
for the development of organoid so
organoid is basically the dr. Han
sleepers group developed organoid by
extracting their gr5 stem cell from the
intestine and they were able to generate
crypto villi intestinal structure in
vitro without enemies in common and they
published his paper in nature from this
technology of generating organoid from
the normal cell they were able to
develop a method to genetically stable
expand the stem cells into organoid
structure that functionally mimicked the
patient original healthy or diseased
epithelium so basically organoid is a
collection of organic organ a specific
cell type which are mainly epithelium
that develop from stem cells organ
progenitors which can self-organize
through a cell sorting and this
restricted commit restricted lineage
commitment in vitro in a manner which is
quite similar to in vivo
so what what is the PDO so PDO is
basically a patient derived organoids so
used using the organoid technology you
can develop organoid from the patient
biopsy sample so generating organoid
from the patient biopsy sample allow a
modeling of human carcinogenesis in
adesh and you can biobank these videos
for long term you can use these PD PD
O's for drug screening freeze them thaw
them use it for into later studies
biomarker identification because they
are very genetically stable so have
organoid so what what what is hub hub is
the commercial entity basically it's a
nonprofit company that was founded
around organoid technology which has
been developed by the dr. Hans clava
scope so how is the very clinically
relevant 3d in vitro model this is the
only available in vitro model which
closely recapitulate genomic
morphological and physiological
characteristics of the corresponding
organ in vivo so these are the flowchart
for the main characteristics of the
you know these are derived from the
adult stem cells they have multiple cell
lineages organoid closely recapitulate
the organ physiological parameters it
maintains the genomic stability it can
be go for long-term culture and kayo
cryopreserved and it can also used for
large-scale screaming now this is a
flowchart for that you know organoid of
epithelial region so develop definitely
we are using hub technology to develop
organoid directly from normal tissue and
patient email you can use this organoid
for the preclinical more pharmacology
modeling in vitro and it can be
developed under defined condition so
this flow chart shows the first is a
primary tissue from the colorectal
patient so the you can take the normal
biopsy sample as well as the tumor from
the same patient so if it is a healthy
cells you can generate a healthy
organoid by using the selective media
such as EGF winter responding if it is a
tumor biopsy you can create a tumor
organoid by using the selective media
and such as lk v inhibitor not lean 3 na
d it has a whole cocktail for the team
organ our generation the system is so
powerful like if you have mixture of
healthy and tumor cells in your biopsy
you can generate either team organoid or
the normal organized from this mixed
sample based on your selective media
cocktail so there are lot of you know
various groups has already published the
powerful nests of d h-- of organoid as
for the predictive preclinical model
this paper recently this paper published
in science in 2018 where the groups have
shown that the patient derived organoid
model treatment response of meta
statistic gastrointestinal cancer where
they have showed that in hundred percent
of cases if a drug didn't work on a
patient organoid which has been
generated in the lab it didn't work in
the patient in the clinic too and almost
the near 90% of the case
if the drug did work on the organoid
then hit work in the patient in clinic 2
so this shows that how this system is
well very powerful for predictive drug
response in the patient in clinic so why
we want to use orgonite interactive
Lippman so this is the only in-vitro
platform presently which is quite
clinically relevant for screening using
this organoid platform we can go for
higher throughput as well as faster
result which compared to the in vivo
models easily scalable to test multiple
drug combinations simultaneously it can
in our you know in valve validation
system at crown bio we have seen it's
highly reproducible compared to primary
cells and in vivo model ensuring that
you know we can use the line for the
future use also for repeat studies we
have seen consistent growth kinetics and
performance across several passages
compared to in vivo model this is very
cost efficient system very low variation
from batch to batch so we can use for
organoid you know we can use match
healthy tissue also if we can from
direct comparison to the tumor model
from the same patient it is very cost
efficient through superior quality
readout compared to the standard other
standard 3d culture systems such as
spheroid or other primary cell culture
in me3 gel this is unique patient
relevant in vitro model with matched in
vivo PDX so we have all these PDX models
which has been over the time validated
for different drug and targeted
therapies and now we are we have planned
to generate organize from all these PDFs
model so we are going to create a
database which we will compare from PD X
so to the parental P DX so optimize
productivity of your drug discovery
program we can have large organized
library act as a surrogate of the
patient population center definitely
slowly when we generate organoid library
we have these are these are they are
going to interact from the patient's of
these theory is going to be very diverse
you know heterogeneous in terms of the
mutation as well as the gene expression
data so prone by our partners with hub
so we have exclusive license to IP
protected have our binoy technology we
can use their technology to generate the
organoid we have access to have living
biobank of PD or PDO are the direct or
denied from the patient sample so we are
going to receive more than 500 PDS from
the hub how PD available at crown by
offer commercial clinical services in
2020 and we are also using our PDX bio
bank to create organoid out of it
so to use to you know to another
generate another library from T for
these PDX model as a PDX oh so this is
the slide showing what are the organoid
services we have so if you see the left
hand side it's orange column where we
are we have the PD patient derived
organoid we call it p do these are model
transferred from the ha we have initial
tumor model with mashed normal patient
tissue for colorectal pancreatic lung
and breast we are going to offer these
models to expand to include ovarian head
and neck cancer now via J we have crown
bio is well known for their PDX
models so we have already
well-established PDS model almost three
thousand in number so we are going to
use all these PDFs model o mainly the
epithelial solid tumor tissue origin for
the derivation of the Arkanoid outer
phase so model built using ground wire
PDS collection as source of human tissue
we have hundreds of model across
multiple cancer types we matched PDX we
can match pd x in vivo model response or
as well as genetic genomic data and we
can screen we can use these pd x so for
the spinning platform now i would like
to talk about generating
pd x territory
library at cranville so this is a
flowchart how we are generating the
library definitely cron bio has a PDS
collection which is very diverse and
patient relevant model we are generated
using well-established beta intent
hub organoid technology for the
generation of PDFs so we are also
comparing the histological features gene
expression mutation profile and
pharmacological sensitivity to these
PDFs so compared to their corresponding
parental PDX model so this is a flow
chart where you can see the pdfs model
we taking out the tumor growth a chunk
too much in front of the minds from the
pdfs model doing which went through the
enzyme and mechanical dissociation and
we are initiating the organoid culture
out of it we further on expanding it and
bio banking it and then we are
characterizing and as saying it for our
NAC TNA seek and compound efficacy test
for each PD XO model generated from the
pd x we are also doing histopathology to
make sure that there is a concordance
between the morphological features of pd
x so from the relevant pdfs model so you
can see the left hand side
histopathology pathology picture where
you can see them off Rajee matches very
well with the pd x compared to the pd x
so i would like to give you some
examples you know like how the organoid
preserve original pd x features we are
comparing side-by-side so here this
slide shows the two model
one is the colorectal model CR 0 5 8 8
the another one is the gastric cancer 0
0 9 1 the upper top picture shows the
organoid structure with pd x so
brightfield images the middle picture
shows the H&E staining for the PDF so
model for CR 0 5 8 8 and thus gee GA 0 0
9 1 and then the last lower panel shows
that gen is training for the relevant
PDFs parental PDS model and you can see
the H&E staining shows very close
mimicking of the most logical structure
between the dis - system we have also
correlating the expression as well as
mutation profile between the PDF so and
PTX and what we have found that we Aman
expression correlation was almost 4
between these two models come for
comparison between PDFs so NPD X the
amount expression correlation was almost
97% and the mutation concordance was
almost 97% this is another example where
we are showing the PDF surface of
original PDFs features here we are using
the lung cancer model generating PD
organoid from EDX model Lu 0 7 4 3 and
Lu 1 2 3 5 and you can see that the H&E
staining the both these two models are
quite mimicking the PD EXO versus
parental PDX model again we have we have
reruns RNA seek as well as comparing the
with a parental pdf's model and you can
see there is a high correlation in
expression and the mutation profile so
the mutation concordance between these
two model while comparing the pd x over
says PDS comes around 97% and the mRNA
expression comes around 92 %
so which shows that the organoid
generation from the PDF so now model
keeping the integrity of the genomic as
genomic features as well as the
morphological features very intact now
we wanted to check the pharmacological
response using these two system so you
can see the left hand side graph which
is 4 we have 4 week for this we have
used Lu 1 2 3 5 XO represent the PDF so
organoid model generate generated from
the particular pd x model and you can
see there left hand side graph shows
that this model was very responsive to
the halacha named chief a tournament
paclitaxel and there was a partial
response in in relation to the cisplatin
treatment and we observed the same
response to the same model pd x model in
vivo tomorrow
Domitian so there was high in this envy
what Yuma growth inhibition was highly
responsive to that lotta name chief a
tenement boxy texture whereas with the
sis black and there was a partial
response this is the another example of
the gastric cancer where we used the PD
EXO and PT x from the model G is three
zero five five and you can see the left
hand graph shows that the organoid from
this model shows in in vitro that there
was no cell response in relation to the
treatment with v fu but for the in vivo
tomorrow at PDX model also showed there
was no response with the primary
treatment so this PDF some model
identify very verified identity verified
by a sent P and pathology they were
highly correlated with the pathology as
well as genomic characterization and we
also the same making as well as the
pharmacological response to so now we
have launched PD EXO screening service
to accelerate practice coffee so how we
are doing it so we are using the patient
relevant in vitro or the noid guide in
vivo PDF so you know we are using or
behind what a lot of our PDFs model to
j'en to guide the selection of the in
vivo pdx models for the optimal
productivity this far
using the organoid as the in vitro drug
screen platform is very fast and
cost-efficient all these organoids are
well annotated for the genomic feature
based on you know RNA expression as well
as a mutation profiling we can which we
can use for the AA mcscreamy so this is
the flowchart how we are doing it so you
know patient population using our pdfs
model you generate the urban art out of
it and then each organoid has been well
characterized for the genomic as well as
the heights for food-truck screening and
this results can tell us like which
model we can go again find vivo
validation using about PDX library
so this is the three study design we are
offering first one is the Lavery
screening so some you have multiple drug
and you want to identify your lead
compound you can use our multiple organ
ID models or one or two organoid model
with number of multiple drugs to use for
screening so this we are doing as a
single or multiple concentration based
on the client design usually the
standard sa involves a triplicate for
each concentration and the endpoint rate
is the CT t cell title or EDA so for
this library skill screening we can use
minimum of 10 compound per model require
the second study design is for the
efficacy quantification so you know your
lead compound and then we want to see
the efficacy of the particular compound
we can choose the multiple organ on
model based on your target or mutation
or gene expression profiling and then
predict the which model is going to
respond for the in vivo using the PDX
model so this is a frequency
quantification based on the standard
ic50 design for usually each drug is run
for nine concentration each
concentration will be in triplicate and
the end point will be the CTD data a
combination strategy comes after the you
know the so combination strategy we have
to run each drug for first
identification of ic50
and then we can go for the combination
regimen so this we are offering the
three matrix one is six by six where we
are using the six concentration of first
truck and the six concentration of the
other drug based on the IC 50 and one is
to nine matrix as the first test agent
will be at fixed concentration and the
other test agent has a nice e 54 matt9
concentration the one is to one fixed
ratio ic50 is the to test agent fixed
ratio diluted together in standard IC 50
format and for all these combination
strategy the endpoint readout will be
the CT j this is the flow chart for the
automated organoid screening platform we
have
waited whole system of organized
screening platform so we have automated
process to improve efficiency and
turnaround we have validated this
automated platform by including the
negative and positive control for inter
and interoperate variation assessment
the standard readout is the C T G and we
are also having the picture for the
mythology in between there sa different
time point we have we can do additional
readout available on request such as
apoptosis cell cycle and biomarker and
at the end of the study there will be
the standardized analysis and the report
will be provided this is just you know
slide 4 showing how we are doing the PD
XO expansion and the drug screening for
men so usually if we expanded our PD XO
in six well form it a drunk drug
screening usually performed in 384 well
foreman compound can be added at same
days or the next day
the endpoint readout is CT G which is
after incubation of organoid with drug
for 5 days and then the bright field
image is to track or biology so if you
see the picture at the lower box bottom
you can see the 6-well plate is the
morphology of the organoid in culture
then a mythology of the organoid before
screening in 6-well plate and then the
mythology of the organoid in 384th plate
in while doing the screening the right
hand side color picture shows the
designing of the plate where we can run
eight compound per plate nine
concentration in triplicate for each
compound and 30 wells per compound the
noid picture shows the mythology of the
compound prideful images of the compound
sorry per brightful images of the
organoid after five days drug incubation
so if you see the top panel where we
incubate the organoid with the control
DMSO there is no aspect and you can see
very clear picture of the organoid
healthy organoid after five days
incubation we are as if the drug has the
response order on the organoid these you
will see the shrinkage
and that's that's what the rightful
images is showing at the lower image
this is of our organized database we
have launched recently so it will give
you the all online database for all our
PDFs so model which has been again
roaring is and rotated for harnessing
all the genomic data as well as any
associative we have perform we also
included the light microscopy and
histopathology data for the PD extra
model these are the feature development
we are trying to develop a lot of essays
using the orgonite PD XO model this is
the hub organoid frame no therapy we are
using we are trying to develop this ton
this system in collaboration with the
hub where we are using the co-culture of
epithelial tumor organoid with
peripheral blood lymphocytes until
definitely no GVHD is often found in
humanized mice and you can use you know
really keep long term out all over
signal so basically we are taking out
the human tissue developing or the noid
out of it and then the PBM see from the
healthy donors from the blood and then
you co culture the organoid with with
the people with activated t-cells and
then you can see you can if you you will
be able to generate the cytotoxic
emphasized this system also can be used
for t-cell interaction for individual
patient and and to understand the
determinants of the responsiveness this
is a slide this is another model we are
trying to develop co-culture model for
the PPD EXO and the allergenic PBMC co
culture by using the in suicide so you
have this PBMCs
po culture with the red label p pd EXO
and then we are observing by the in
suicide like is there any ste cell
cytotoxicity on this organ ID if you see
the left hand side panel the top panel
shows the effector target ratio which is
to is to 200 is to 1 and you can see at
zero hour there are lot of you know
organoid here but once after 24-hour you
can see there is a very less red labeled
organoid but with the target only you
can see only the there is no effect
definitely because there is no t-cell
here this is the P DX so and hello Janek
PBMC co-culture platform also we are
developing where we are using the frozen
PBM severe considering these frozen PBMC
for 72 hours with the entire city 3 and
cd28 culture for to activate the t-cell
and then we are labeling p DX of HC c f
SC then we are co culturing this
activated t-cell with the p DX so a
different effect on target ratio for 3
days we are using the facts analysis to
see the cytotoxicity of the t-cell or on
organoid so if you see the right top
panel graphical representation well you
can clearly see that with the activated
PBMC they are more number of dead or
organoid compared to the knife PBMC the
lower panel shows the facts
representation only says just a raw data
where you can see these these are those
responses in relation to the effective
target ratio the activated PBMC has more
toxicity on organoid when we are come to
a 20 is to 1 when we are using effector
to target ratio 20 is to 1 compared to
the target only or 10 is to 1 or 2 is to
1 effector target ratio and there was no
difference between the knife PBMCs we
also want to see whether these if we are
going to put PDF so in in vivo model
whether there is a similar growth
characteristics but in comparison to the
appearance of PT x model so if you see
this graphical representation the blue
the navy blue and the orange line
representing the pd x so engraftment in
mice at the different cell number and
then the grey purple and the blue line
shows the particular pd x model
engraftment in vivo and you can see that
there is very similar
growth characteristics when you compare
the PD EXO invivo
as well as the PTX in vivo so this
suggests as that PDX will maintain to
merge in a city when engrafted in vivo
and then the PD EXO derived in vivo
graft model show similar growth
characteristics to corresponding PDFs
now these organoids definitely as it is
an in vitro system it can be easily
engineered by Christopher our
transduction and other technologies we
are trying to generate new PD EXO model
which can be fluorescent or
bioluminescent
cabled organoid so we can you know if we
put these PD EXO labelled with Roy
center value recent label you can track
the migration of tumor cells in
different organ in mice we are also
trying to develop the drug resistant
model out of this organoid based on our
in vivo data
PDX data where the pdfs model is
resistant to suppose the EGFR inhibitor
or other targeted agent so we are you
choosing those periods
PDX model which were resistant to the
targeted agent or you know and then
developing organoid out of it which can
be used for the drug and drug
combination based on the mechanism of
faction or you know target this is the
automated biomarker discovery platform
so we are generating you know huge
database based on the NGS data sets for
from matched patient
PDX as well as pdfs mod p d XO which we
are going to use for our silicon in
silicon trucked in silico discovery we
are using our bioinformatics team to
discover predictive mile marker because
we have this three system and all these
systems system has been well annotated
for genomic data as well as the efficacy
data so it will be a huge help to find
out the predictive biomarkers for based
on you know client interest or study
design so this is the organoid platform
summary patient relevant 3d in vitro
system organ
providing a new approach to preclinical
drug development definitely it's a very
fast establishment and high throughput
compared to the any in vivo models it
can easily scalable for large-scale drug
discovery including combination or
single drug it has very superior in
vitro system based on our observation
because of the higher quality readout
very higher signal and the lower
background ratio we are seeing very less
variation from batch to batch compared
to the standard 2d and 3d cell culture
do you Morgan I derive from patient or
PDX tumor recap surely to the in vivo
tumorigenesis and definitely it's
preserving the genomic features
comparing to the corresponding tumors in
english' we definitely we are slowly
growing a large library of orgonite and
it is going to represent the
heterogeneity of the patient population
and definitely help to predict in vivo
tumor drug response pd x OPD XO is
basically basically from the pd x
derived organoid and it are only
available from the patient element in
vitro system so using this system we can
go for further studies using the peat
for the in vivo pd x model for optimal
productivity in so we can screen number
of drug using the PD XO and based on the
PD XO model of service response to the
particular term we can choose the
particular pd x model to again identify
whether the particular whether the drug
is effective in in vivo large library of
annotated pete PDX so with corresponding
PDX data will provide a lot of
opportunities automated biomarker
discovery we have planned to develop a
future platform which involves organoid
engineering or establishment of organoid
arrived in vivo models and then
application to amount and thank you for
your time